[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream 93rd q and a
it is time
do we have the cues
we do we do
um so we're going to start there are a
few coded questions we're going to start
with some code questions and then move
on to a bunch of other stuff
let's just launch
first question the amplification of
merrick's disease due to leaky vaccines
this was in chickens
has me concerned about evolution of
covid with lockdowns in modern society
the selective pressure the selective
pressures on a disease are to have
symptoms mild enough that you can go
into work or school to spread it around
it may even select for asymptomatic
spread so you don't have so you don't
take sick days
with lockdowns most of the spread
happens in hospitals where the most
virulent strains go to spread and don't
require mobility of the host
should we worry
that is an extremely insightful question
the idea being if i can
put in a slightly different context
you've got pathogens that depend on the
comparative well-being of their host in
order that the host gets in contact with
other potential hosts and spreads the
disease
right and then you have
a few pathogens in which incapacitating
the host actually facilitates
transmission things like malaria and
yellow fever where being incapacitated
leaves you more likely to be bitten by a
mosquito right the distinction there
being that they're vectored rises
so the point here is is the hospital
playing the role of the mosquito where
the idea is making you vulnerable to the
hospital actually has a an upside from
the point of view of the pathogen it's a
fascinating question i do think this is
exactly the sort of thing we need to
worry about
and that the
thing that one hears very frequently
which has a certain uh substantial truth
in it
is that pathogens tend to evolve to be
more benign over time more transmissible
and more benign
um but that is not that's a rule of
thumb and the real question is what is
the mode of transmission and to the
extent that we are affecting it are we
uh capable of driving them in the other
direction well frankly as you were
saying that i'm reminded of you know the
rule of thumb
island dwarfism right um well on on
islands things get smaller right well
no they get smaller if they started out
big
and they get bigger they started out
small on islands things tend to change
in response to selective pressures that
are different on the island compared to
the mainland from which the organism
came and so you've got some rule of
thumb that in many people's heads who
think about such things becomes like the
rule oh what is going on in this weird
case where things got bigger instead
it's like well the rule you had was just
a rule of thumb and you need to be doing
the first principle stuff and so i don't
know exactly exactly how that maps on
here but it's something similar where
you know in general
in general a disease um that has a
specific in particular that has um a
very specific host will tend to become
less virulent and more transmissible
over time uh but not necessarily yeah
and i'm uh
reminded of the horrifying story that we
just learned
about the deer up in the san juan
islands on
san juan island and
orcas island apparently both populations
were
wiped out something like 90 of the deer
were lost in a very short period of time
as a result of a virus so we we just we
talked to a guy like a you know a park
guide um i don't know that he said that
number for orcas he said the virus the
virus got to the deer on orcas but he
was specifically talking he gave that 90
percent number of fruits
i've since i have since looked it up but
uh in any case
90 virus comes over from the mainland
something that circulates uh among
um deer on
in mainland populations got onto the
islands where it was not uh initially
and wiped out in a matter of months
ninety percent of the deer so um and
extremely a couple months ago extremely
virulent uh pathogen and the question
is to what extent
does the island isolation of those
populations leave them more vulnerable
uh what exactly happened and what will
be the fate of this virus going forward
did the virus burn itself out was the 10
of the deer that were left standing uh
immune to the virus in which case the
virus might well be again extinct on
these islands
are they actually harboring the virus
and they are tolerant to it in which
case what will their descendants be like
there are a lot of interesting questions
but i would say beware rules of thumb
because they may well mislead you indeed
indeed
yeah great question
would you both be willing to share what
you currently do to protect yourselves
from coven behavioral changes iremectin
doses etc
um you know we're
using the advertised ivermectin dose i
will say that um the
the original one the original one yeah
yeah i'm concerned about doubling it as
is the current recommendation uh i would
say we were both being very cautious
about contacting
um we're contacting people we don't know
who might have coveted
and you know it at the moment it's still
summer so it's pretty easy right
we continue to eat in restaurants but
we're doing so outside as much as
possible
uh and um
and
you know
the the distancing you know
frankly if
if people are actually not protected
from the virus the idea that walking
into a restaurant with a mask on and
then sitting down and having all of the
people eating there with their masks off
is somehow
somehow safe is is
right
um so
you know one one hopes that people have
in those situations immunity from um
one of several several several means
that we've talked about natural immunity
from having had the disease
uh natural immunity from having had a
vaccine vaccination or other prophylaxis
in the form of either repurposed drugs
like ivermectin or other
other things like a combination of d and
c and zinc and such yeah i would say
d being the obvious cheapest
intervention that seems to be highly
effective apparently there's something
the
i believe the statistic is correct that
people with a d deficiency have a
uh much higher is it 40 percent
increased likelihood of contracting
covert in a given situation as far as we
know so
a very cheap intervention
um but
the other thing i would say is
there are two
prongs here you've got how do you
prevent yourself from contracting covid
and were you to catch covid what would
you do and
um
i i would say
be prepared to treat it aggressively
that one of the many ways in which our
public health authorities are failing us
is that we do have a series of drugs
that appear to be very effective at
reducing the severity of the disease
and we are pretending that we don't have
any and yeah
so be prepared to treat it aggressively
and aggressively means immediately um
yeah it does and i mean i guess the
other stuff which we we tend to do
a good job in life in general but um we
are being even more cognizant
of um of our diet and activity yep and
you know we we we eat whole foods and we
eat you know we shop farmers markets and
the edges of grocery stores and donate
much processed food and you know all of
that is is true anyway but uh you know
ferment and um whole organisms
uh in as much as possible and um
and and really really getting your body
moving on a regular basis like not not
just walks which are fabulous and you
know taking a lot of walks is very good
for you but um working up a sweat and
you know getting set you know getting
moving such that you really you know you
feel it during and afterwards
is
um
is protective against all manner of
things presumably including certain
viruses
okay next one sort of sort of uh
in the same theme like i said there's
five questions here uh covedy this is
number three
role play scenario
be infected with the delta variant with
no access to medications
or get one of the
vaccines which would you pick and why
this is a very hard role play because
what we don't know
is you know be infected with the delta
variant does that you know how many
asymptomatic cases are there in which
you walk away
with durable immunity if that number is
very very high right then
in some sense because the
vaccine effectiveness is dropping with
respect to uh the evolution of variance
you know there's an argument i think we
just don't know enough so yeah well it's
also there's like it's it's a point in
time right so like you know for this
moment the answer might be different but
if given that you have to live in your
own body for the next three years
like okay are you are you saying that
you can get vaccinated then you're
totally protected forever after which we
know you aren't right which we know we
aren't so
yeah i mean and and the other thing is
that the scenario it's very hard to put
oneself in the mindset of
you don't have access to drugs having
been
having been infected
because
those drugs exist and they definitely
affect the calculation so i mean i guess
yeah i mean at some level
we're really lucky we don't live in that
world
and um this is something we were
beginning to say a couple couple three
maybe four months ago
which was
a number of things that we're seeing
in
the data that we as members of the
public are allowed access to
is concerning
and
how
how grateful are we that there do seem
to be a number of
of drugs including you know common
vitamins that are available on every on
every shelf that sells such things
uh that are understood to be effective
in both uh prophylaxis and treatment and
um
you know
yes ivermectin is also on that list but
with regard to common things like c and
d and zinc
um it's you know it's just a it's just a
no-brainer and so you know it is
impossible to imagine the world in which
those things
aren't available
i i think it is also the case people
will hear us having this discussion and
think you've lost your minds why you
know most people get the vaccine and
don't have a negative reaction and it
does it is somewhat effective at
preventing
the disease
or contraction of the disease the
problem is this the reason it's not a
simple question
is we can't take something like ade
off the list of possible consequences
enhancement right and so if ade happens
then the point is the vaccines have a
cost that we cannot yet measure and that
cost comes in the form of uh enhancing
the hazard of covet 19. so yeah it's a
very difficult puzzle and i think the
thing that is driving me crazy and i
think you crazy is
there does not appear to be any
commitment to
a holistic analyses of you know the
things we know there's no commitment to
analyzing the adverse events and
figuring out what fraction of them
actually are related to the vaccines so
we can't calibrate
the hazard we can't calibrate the degree
to which those things might be mitigated
if we treated the post-vaccine syndromes
we can't calibrate
um the true hazard of the disease
because we're not tracking it properly
um and anyway it makes it a very hard
puzzle i think you know
if if i had to take the scenario at face
value i guess i would take the vaccine
rather than
contract the delta variant but it
doesn't mean that that's you know x anti
that's the right choice but if ade turns
out to um
to be an important component here then
it could be exactly the wrong choice
yeah
um
i agree
i agree and given um
given given some new new research that
that seems to be out but i mean the the
data stream is more polluted by the day
it's less trustworthy by the day and so
it's very hard to know what is actually
true but
um
we
continue to
i will say i continue to believe and i
believe that you do as well
that
the adenovirus factor vaccines like j
have fewer novel elements associated
with them than the mrna vaccines
and given that there is for instance new
research out um that is finding promise
in some
new um
lipid nanoparticle
chemistry i think it was
um that has fewer of the costs of
what are currently in the mrna vaccines
um
and it's a you're allowed to talk about
this if what you're doing is trying to
figure out a new kind of a vaccine to
create but you're not allowed to talk
about this if that's not the business
you're in
if if this was the situation um i think
i would i would prefer the adenovirus
vector
yeah vaccines and i think actually
we missed one of the advantages of the
adenovirus
vaccine which is that because it's a
single dose one doesn't run the risk
that amping up the immune system the
first time then causes an increased
likelihood of uh adverse reaction on the
second encounter yep
yep that's true
do you i feel like maybe we've done this
one before but do you have a take on
covid and the spike protein in the
vaccine affecting cellular senescence
and telomere shortening what could be
done to prevent it yeah we've we've
talked about this which is
anything that is destructive of cells
increases the rate of senescence whether
it's a an appreciable amount is unclear
this is presumably a feature of
more standard vaccines too to the extent
that if you have something that's like
an attenuated virus based vaccine it
infects cells presumably those cells are
then uh destroyed by the immune system
so all of these things will increase the
rate of senescence and therefore
telomere loss
the question is is it appreciable
yeah
certainly the disease itself does such
damage to the body that there will be
significant losses in terms of repair
capacity going forward yeah yeah for
sure
okay thank you for answering my question
recently about ivermectinous prophylaxis
i shared this info with my doctor
including multiple studies as well as
your sub stack and driving sorry's cov2
to extinction and his response was
thanks for the info still not convincing
enough to prescribe by vermectin sorry
about that do you have thoughts on this
yeah um
i don't understand it
because you know in effect there's
clearly a propaganda campaign designed
to make ivermectin seem more dangerous
than it is and in the absence of that
danger the obvious thing to do is to
prescribe it in a case where
you know if you've just sent somebody
home
to
sick and in place
why wouldn't you prescribe it and why
wouldn't you prescribe it to the people
that they are likely to give the virus
to yeah who live in their house right so
at some level much hinges on the idea of
dangers that have been amplified
specifically to justify a
conclusion which is it's the evidence
isn't good enough to prescribe it and
the answer is if the cost of prescribing
it is very very low the evidence doesn't
have to be especially strong to justify
it
and you know and the evidence is pretty
good right so what i would say is
you know
a a
sophist can turn the hippocratic oath on
its head
and the idea is
do nothing because some remote
possibility of harm exists rather than
do that which makes harm least likely
right yeah that's good and i think
that's where we are unfortunately yeah
okay one more covered question came in
then we'll switch gears here
um i heard that both sars kobe 1 and
mers appear to have gone extinct after
two years without homo sapiens
intervention
is there a plausible two-year
self-terminating cycle for stars kobe 2.
so i've never heard this no that it i
think this is our best understanding
uh
i don't think so i think
certainly
what is our best understanding that they
went extinct
two years like like the thing that i've
never heard is like there's this two
like this too oh i don't know if there's
anything magic about that yeah that
strikes me as very unlikely
um
i don't think there's anything plausible
to do here but i will say we keep doing
the dumb thing right the dumb thing
anytime you have a wave that is
decreasing that you've crested and
you're now on the downslope
are not is below one what we do
is we then relax and start behaving more
normally which then causes the next wave
and
really the point is if you can keep or
not below one you're on the path to the
extinction of the virus but we've blown
this so many times that uh it is going
to be a much harder job to deal with it
and
um
you know well i mean with each with each
failure it becomes less and less
possible that you can you can do it
because
because people are done well people are
just done people are not just exhausted
and
tired of this but they're you know
they're literally going broke
and um they're watching their children
fall apart in front of them and it you
know just
some number of people who take the
disease very seriously and have been
doing everything they can to do what the
health officials are telling them to do
are at the point of saying to hell with
it i'm just i'm i'm done
and you know that that is just a human
response and uh i don't i at this point
i don't see a way out of that spiral no
but i do think it is very important to
point out that
uh
you know people continue to blame us for
stuff this is something we were very
clear about early on that the point was
it's not pro-lockdown or anti-lockdown
what we probably needed was extremely
intensive short-term measures right
basically
prevent all but absolutely essential
interaction for something like
six weeks
then it would burn it this was before we
understood that there were
viable treatments and and prophylactics
before the vaccines
and the idea was it's very difficult to
prevent it from spreading within a
within a household so it needs time to
burn out right within those households
in order um to to get to a place where
we could get are not permanently below
one but
uh in any case we we have now blown it
and you're right now the idea of getting
anybody to um be enthusiastic about
draconian measures especially measures
that go beyond anything that we've
seen yet is it's implausible but again
that's the result of
very
uh lackluster public health officials
that have deployed a policy that was at
best so utterly inept that it couldn't
possibly have worked and there was an
obvious public enemy and it was the
virus and instead um you know first
at this point it's the unvaccinated
and you know there's that's the official
line is that it's the unvaccinated no
that's the public enemy so that is what
is what is being created as the public
enemies the the virus should have been
the public enemy that was created by the
public health campaign and there was a
series of you know was it trump was it
trump supporters was it you know people
who i don't even i can't even remember
all the stages we went through but we
sort of landed on
this um this
really insane and divisive and not in
any way helpful
tribalism
in which
it's even less likely
that that people who think that they
have been virtuous and done everything
that is necessary
would
would concede to any further
restrictions um given that they've been
told that they're in the right and
they've done everything they need to do
yes
by a public health um authority that
clearly doesn't know what it's doing or
unfortunately does in which case we
don't know what it's actually trying to
accomplish because so much rides on this
i'm going to clarify what might not
otherwise require clarification those
people may morally be in the right
they've done what they were told and
they did it in large measure for
civilization's benefit whether what they
were told makes any sense is a different
question and what role those who have
been vaccinated are playing in the
ongoing pandemic is not the one that
they are being led to understand so
this idea that it is the unvaccinated
that are the source of the
uh variants that escape the immunity
induced by the vaccines is nonsense it's
evolutionary nonsense the fact is
it's selection that does that and the
selection
that beat the vaccines didn't come from
the unvaccinated it happened in the
vaccinated so
um
in any case yes the unvaccinated are
being demonized for some social
political purpose even though logically
this makes no sense and that's where we
are
good
i mean not actually bad bad
uh but i don't blame you
awesome yeah
okay total change of topic here next
question
what evolutionary function does
emotional sensitivity play this being
the predisposition predisposition that
leads to
[Music]
i didn't see that coming okay let me
read this now that i know where we're
going here what evolutionary function
does emotional sensitivity play this
being the predisposition that leads to
borderline personality disorder when
childhood trauma occurs
it involves feeling that all emotions
off the scale compared to other people
much greater empathy etc
and how is it a disadvantage in today's
society as compared to psychopathy which
seems to be an asset
boy there's a lot in this um yeah
including a lot of assumptions yeah i'm
not i'm not sure i'm not sure how many
of these assumptions are warranted
um you know emotional sensitivity is to
some degree what allows us to have
theory of mind
which is utterly necessary to being
human it's not you know it's not just
emotional sensitivities it's like mental
sensitivity psychological sensitivity
it's clearly an optimality problem yeah
what is the optimal level of sensitivity
to other people's emotions and and i
mean there's something in here that's
actually sort of describing a continuum
and the assumption is like psycho
psychopathy is at one end of an
emotional sensitivity continuum and
borderline is it the other
um and i don't i just don't know
you know yes in combination with trauma
etc but i don't
i don't feel like i feel like there's a
lot of places that being highly
emotionally attuned
um can lead that has nothing to do with
with borderline at all yeah uh yeah
unfortunately i feel like pushing back
on almost every one of the claims there
which doesn't mean there's nothing in
those claims but it means i don't think
there are claims that you can simply say
this is true this is true this is true
you know for one thing
psychopathy i don't think psychopathy as
i understand it is almost ever
an advantage
sociopathy
uh very frequently is
but um either either we're going to
synonymize those and then we've got a
problem
because we've lost resolution or we're
not going to synonymize them
uh
and
um
so anyway i i don't i i don't i just
don't think that the model
as presented in a single question
is
capable of supporting
um
the weight necessary to yep
to answer it fair enough um i am
reminded
somehow by my brain
but there's a there's a discord question
this week as well which i never see now
because we're using this different
system
you are reminded by your brain that's
interesting
yeah and again of course now you know
when i search
okay um i'm gonna ask unfortunately the
moderator once again to send it to me um
on text if that's possible and i'll pick
up my phone in a couple of minutes um
because i saw it earlier and my mail
program is not finding it
okay
um
you and your brain are in agreement
about that for now yeah cool
[Laughter]
um do you have any thoughts on catherine
i don't know how to pronounce your last
name do you have any thoughts on
catherine berbelsing
uh the headmistress at the michaela
school in the uk
she's very successful and the school is
very successful and she's a fan of
structure her interview on trigonometry
is eye opening so i i know of her i have
not seen her in trigonometry i did see
her a couple years ago on dave reuben
and she's she's fascinating she is um
like the person asked in the question
suggests
the headmistress at the school
i think it's kate i think it's a k-12
school in the uk
um that is
is very strict
uniforms
um i think there's a very set curriculum
um you know very very much more in the
traditional model maybe a little bit
more in the model of the school that you
were invited to leave
um and then came to this school that you
that you and i met at
um
and
she seems to be an extraordinary
educator who has landed on a model that
is
very much different from the one that
we the ones that we were innovating
um and i think what she is doing will
work for some people
but it would not work for everyone
well
i wonder if the problem isn't the
benevolent dictator problem
but because she is i i i think she
appears to be so good at what she does
and she cares so deeply about the
students um that uh
that the system will work because she's
because she is right a benevolent
dictator a benevolent dictator who um
knows what they're doing
right is the best form of government the
problem is there's no mechanism for
choosing a benevolent dictator and so
what you get is the powers of a dictator
in the hands of somebody who will use
them like most dictators do yeah and so
my point here would just simply be
there's nothing wrong with structure if
structure is wielded by somebody who's
highly insightful and um
you know
capable of utilizing it to maximal
effect it may even be the best way to go
about things the problem is
if you say ah she's got a method right
and it involves tons and tons of
structure then who exactly does that
method get handed off to and you know at
what point are you looking at an
authoritarian structure with no insight
i mean i i certainly i used structure
yeah
sure um i you know i i really did
architect curriculum uh and but it had a
lot of space for um diversions and
serendipity um
and and other things but let's just take
for instance the the discussion of
school uniforms uh which has been had
many many times by many many people and
i
you know i i never
was at a place that had uniforms
i never had to succumb to them
but the argument in favor of them that
i've heard that rings somewhat true to
me
is that at least in some circumstances
that is to say in some environments uh
having that choice taken from you
such that you are not signaling to other
people either your status or you know
your status within a social circle or
your membership
your wealth your family wealth or your
membership in some group
allows for greater focus on who you are
on the inside
oh
i actually think school uniforms are
probably a good idea
because there's all kinds of
runaway competition and stuff and you
know neutralizing all of that yeah look
i hope people don't get the wrong idea
when structure fails
it fails spectacularly right
and there's a lot to be said for a
person who is capable of navigating when
there is no structure and somebody who
deploys structure really well
will deploy it in such a way that when
you remove that structure the person is
not incapable but highly capable
so the point is it becomes very easy to
look at overly structured things and
think structure is the problem and
that's not it you know i wish i had had
a really well structured education from
somebody who really understood human
minds and children and all of that i
would have avoided a lot of the things
that got in my way and still get in my
way
but absent that right the last thing the
worst of all possible worlds is the
structure without the insight right the
structure in the hands of people who are
incapable of dealing with the moral
obligation that comes along with
administering it and that's what you
tend to get so um you know there's sort
of a hierarchy here but yes
um the structure isn't the problem it's
bad structure
what is your advice for kids who are
planning for college our oldest two kids
are the same age as your boys and we're
trying to figure out how not to spend a
fortune on education that will do more
harm than good
thanks
we don't have good advice at this point
unfortunately yeah i mean i i wish we
did we're all in it together at some
level because do you really you know it
makes no sense to spend huge sums of
money and even more important than the
money the most important years of your
kids developmental life potentially
maybe i take that back but most
important years from the point of view
of them finding their
place in the world
and spending them learning
uh
false garbage or pretending that they're
learning false garbage right this is
such an incredible waste
on the other hand deciding uh college is
done so i'm not going to send my kids
because it's not worthwhile
depends on the world recognizing that it
wasn't an important component
and that's an awfully risky thing to do
so yeah there's there's nothing good to
say and i guess uh in lieu of something
useful to say
we had every obligation to recognize
that this was happening and headed off
at the pass and having failed to do that
we are now facing a collective
catastrophe and we can also see what
that's going to produce which is a
society full of people who are incapable
of running even basic operations so
that's where we're headed and it's an
emergency yeah it is um
at the i'm not sure this is useful or
not but at the practical level i used to
recommend
um
i used to
really feel strongly that for
undergraduate
uh a small liberal arts college uh was
the right place because you didn't you
couldn't slide into anonymity and you
had a better chance of being in a small
class with hopefully an excellent
teacher and and engaged peers and could
discover things you had no idea existed
or that you were interested in before
and that if you wanted to go on to
graduate school for instance
um then then you wanted the big the r1
the big the major research institution
that had as many people flowing through
as possible you know as many talks that
you would go to in a day that you could
you know choose to go to or not as
possible um and uh you know that would
also allow you the capacity to you know
pay for your graduate school by teaching
or doing research whatever
given that the small liberal arts
colleges
are more easily
captured by
a silly ideology and
largely captured by silly ideology at
this point
i no longer think that's the right
choice um and it's terrible because
really a liberal arts education is is a
fabulous thing when it works but it's
very hard to know where you might find
it now so to some degree veering towards
the larger schools even as even for
undergrads
is one of the things that is one of the
ways that i my thinking has pivoted um
over the last really like five seven
eight years like since before evergreen
blew up
um
i i see why it pivots away
from the small liberal arts colleges but
even though it seems like the the
research one
the larger schools auto have been
resistant
we know they weren't and we know that it
extends even to places that you would
think are perfectly immune like math
right so given that
yes it's an emergency and
the fact that you are scratching your
head trying to figure out what to do for
your own kids
the only thing we can say is that that's
not the result of the fact that you've
overlooked something yeah
i am starting a career as a biology
teacher on monday ninth grade how can i
use what you outlined to be the best
possible teacher to my students and how
do i teach or learn evolution what book
would you recommend
uh what a big fun question yeah that's a
great question yeah
uh the selfish gene is
it's it's getting
it's showing its age because it's
finally like you know published in 1976
yeah it's still classic it's amazing how
current it is and what's in it is
largely right yeah um what isn't in it
is the problem right so updating for
things like uh epigenetic effects are is
is an important addendum but
i would say it's probably still the best
place to go to learn the basics of this
style of thinking and then on the macro
side um
ancestors tale also by dawkins so
selfish gene for the microevolutionary
stuff you have adaptive evolution
and for um you know origin of species
and deep history of species ancestors
tale also by dawkins yeah and uh
i'm still um
fond of climbing mount improbable just
as in terms of a
way to
encapsulate the style of thinking right
so that you understand sort of what
design space looks like in the way
selection explores it
but um
i i don't know that this is any use to
you but one of the exercises i used to
do in my classes was to take a
documentary
a nature documentary and go through it
such that anybody in the class could
shout pause at any moment and try to
figure out whether what is being said
makes sense and what it predicts about
other things and how you would test that
and so i guess what i'm really saying is
not that exercise is necessarily what
you want to engage with
but that there's no substitute for
doing for trying out your thinking
rather than absorbing it
bless you sorry about that
um oh you were done yep okay
um
in terms of
teaching um well in terms of both
evolution and teaching we you know we
have some of that also in in our book
but that's not out yet it'll be out
september 14th um i do have a couple of
pieces on um i'm now putting everything
on substance but a couple pieces on my
medium so here's one zach you just show
my screen for a second um
this is
on
medium.com
at highing h
um called the twin virtues of trust and
uncertainty and there's there's pieces
from this also in the chapter on school
but this describes some of the things
that that i in particular but many of
the things that brett and i both did in
the classroom
um that was particularly effective
we found uh with and you know i think
you know teen teaching high schoolers is
going to be different from teaching
college students um but it's not wholly
different and i think a lot of the same
a lot of the same things will apply yeah
i'm not so sure how it's going to be
different at the level of what they can
handle assignment-wise but um
in terms of
how one reaches them other than maybe
being
i don't know are they more distracted in
high school
but
i i don't know i actually suspect
there's not that much difference you
know who we are in high school is
largely
who we are in college from the point of
view of our intellectual development and
uh
you know the same the same things are
useful for for reaching and uh
cultivating those minds
i think there are a lot of people who
hang out with a lot of teenagers who are
going to think that you've never met a
teenager
i have two of them i know but they're um
they're not typical i think
ah because we talked to them like adults
from the beginning and you know shoved
them in with undergraduates at a young
age
which oh my dad
so
all right
next question
i don't grasp the cross-lateral purpose
of the brain hemispheres
why did evolution do this do all
vertebrates central nervous system do
this
what do you think of mcgill christ's
master and his emissary
so we've we've talked about this before
unfortunately we've talked about so many
things so many places who know who knows
where
um
i mean there are a couple of different
things mcgill crest is mostly not um
he's he's great and um
and
he is mostly not talking about the
history of lateralization in the cns
which yes all vertebrates
have lateralization and then mammals
have this corpus callosum which
basically is the bundle of nerve fibers
that allows the
communication between the left and right
hemispheres separately birds have a
different structure i've forgotten the
name of it um which allows for the
communication between the two
hemispheres other vertebrates uh
certainly have some
some communication but not nearly as
much and uh early in vertebrate
evolution you have what be later becomes
as fruitable hemispheres basically as
like olfactory stocks um not even
connected to one another off of the
front end of the
uh of the brain as part of the the
telecephalon
um so
you know they're they're doing stuff
early that then in mammals in particular
the cerebral hemispheres become
become engaged with
um scenario building and memory
recollection and the synthesis of
interpretation and and perception and
and thought
that
it is now important not just useful not
not just useful but actually necessary
to allow those two hemispheres to
connect to communicate with one another
but it can also be useful to have part
of your brain not be fully
fully
on board with everything that's
happening in the rest so you know
compartmentalization
um has a bad rap but it actually has
utility right so having two parts of
your brain two sides of your brain that
are both connected and not so connected
that they can't do things out of reach
of the other
except for when
errors happen accidents happen
it can actually be a very productive way
to have a brain
i thought you were poor to say no okay
well i okay i will not say more no
um
what animal behavior
were you able to witness that was most
fascinating
like an individual instance
i read the question
well
let's see i mean for me
i have
once seen a bird riding another bird
i thought that was fantastic
really yeah do i was i there nope you're
not present what do you know what bird
i don't know what the bird doing the
writing was it was riding a crow
i have now seen this documented
elsewhere stirrups
nope um
i guess you know i for sheer
fascination the
incident with the tyra's
uh killing a sloth
uh tyra is a
mustelid a weasel an arboreal or
semi-arboreal weasel in the neotropics
and i happened on some noise in a
patch of forest and followed it and uh
there were two tyra's that were
attacking and killing a sloth
um
and uh
i was in a very tough spot actually you
know you guys weren't too far back and i
ran back up the trail to get you guys to
come see it and i assumed it would be
gone by the time we got back but they
were so distracted they didn't even see
me we watched it for a good half an hour
40 minutes yeah so that was pretty yeah
um
pretty wild
i did manage to see a bat and in fact
was able to
video capture his back on videotape the
building of a tent by
a
neotropical bat that was a behavior that
had never been seen before
i don't know those are all all pretty
good
yeah i don't i don't have it categorized
this way i just i
every time i go out
and spend time in nature i see
it's harder in the temperate zone
because there's fewer animals there's
less diversity
um but pretty much every time i go out
into any kind of
nature that's intact i see something
amazing and um
you know when i when i was doing my
research in madagascar every day i saw
just extraordinarily elaborate
courtships between these tiny poison
frogs and fights these wrestling matches
between these frogs they'd be up you
know belly to belly like sumo wrestlers
up against one another
um and parental care
that both males and females and uh
and
other species moving in on the
territories and and keeping the um the
guys that i was researching out of the
territories by barking at them other
species of frogs
um
and
uh
and you know then overhead there'd be
like verisia these rough lemurs tearing
apart a jackfruit
or a you know chameleon down down below
um you know doing their incredibly slow
walk that looks like they don't know
what they're doing but they're actually
being super cryptic
um
you know boa shows up at some point and
chomps down on one of the frogs
and uh slowly slowly chews on it for a
while all other frog activity stops this
particularly loud moment in frog land so
there's a lot of calling and suddenly
everyone's quiet and there's just this
boa
chewing slowly on this frog and i was a
frog i'd mark so i knew it was a female
frog
i knew who it was um and after about 15
minutes the boa
releases the frog
i never see this bow again the boat had
been living under the bamboo stand where
all these territories were
and the frog was bloody
but went on to become a mom and uh give
parental care to her kids so um you know
she survived presumably by dent of the
poison otherwise the boat would have
just eaten her um so
it's just so much all the time when
you're out there and and you slow down
enough
the nature can come back alive around
you
and
you don't
require that it looked like what you
imagined it was going to look like
all right um i read dr rollergater's
three articles about vaccine advocacy
amazing are there other sources looking
into this it's such a bombshell i don't
know where to go to confirm it thanks
i don't know if anyone um not on the
same angle it's uh worth looking at
matthew crawford's sub stack he's
looking at a different uh angle but it's
also quite interesting
um i think his sub stack is called
rounding the earth
i think that's right um yeah yeah yeah
that's good matthew 1 t crawford
um
this one i think is a just a mis
memory or misread of something we said
so could you clarify the data you
explored in stream 90 that shows younger
vaccinated people are more likely to die
from cover 19 than those who are not
and i think this is about um one of
those dr rollergater articles that we
cite in
in that sub-stack piece
where i live the data shows
vaccinated people are having better
outcomes
um well i so i would say
it's very hard to know what the data
show and so what dr religator does is
actually when the data are available
goes and does the analysis but
nothing that we have seen
from him
nor said i'm
certain
suggests that younger vaccinated people
are more likely to die that's not
that's absolutely not true
um what he what
his re-analysis of the actual data um
showed if i remember correctly is that
um the s the apparently strong signal
uh that vaccinated people are far less
likely to have bad out bad outcomes um
cannot can is is not actually a pattern
that you see in the data when you do the
math right
they are less likely to have bad
outcomes by virtue of reduced
contraction of the disease but beyond
that what we are told is not reflected
in the data that's right
um
totally different question thoughts on
the current situation in afghanistan
um
yeah i mean unfortunately
a lot of things that everybody will have
thought which is to what extent
was this huge investment pointless
and i would say it's not a slam dunk
that it was pointless even to the extent
that it ends with um
this particular catastrophe because of
course there was a 20-year period in
there
in which something else happened and
what ultimately will be the effect of
that
uh that difference i don't know but i
mean 20 years is enough time for
somebody to become you know to be born
and
yeah uh
become an adult
uh so
yeah it's it's an absolute tragedy and
it's
obviously being incredibly badly handled
on the other hand there's a question
about
what we thought we were doing in the
first place and
how plausible it was
yeah i don't i i actually had just begun
to listen to um barry weiss's latest
podcast with uh general mcmaster
um and you know as usual there's nuance
and depth there and um
i don't know enough
i don't know enough it's clearly it's
clearly a mess all the way all the way
around but um
but i can't say more than you've said
here
um
full disclosure i took the j j in march
finally some good news for us jay and
jayers a study indicates that j j might
actually be better at dealing with a
delta variant than the mrna vaccines why
might this be broader spectrum question
mark
so i'd like to see i feel like i've
heard something about that but i haven't
seen the study i'd like to know i'd like
to see the actual research yep um i
can't think of a mechanistic reason i
can't think of a mechanistic reason
either but it could be
you know
we talked at length about the fact that
one of the things about the mrna
vaccines is that there's no
obvious calibration for how many of
these
mrnas make it into how many different
cells and right and all of that and at
least the adenovirus vectored stuff is
using basically the ecology of an
adenovirus in order to introduce this
novel uh mrna i mean dna to create this
protein but um
that's there's at least a mechanism
there that something other than
nanoparticle covered mrna bumping into
cells finding their way into the mrna
finding its way into the cytoplasm and
being transcribed so
there may be something in the systematic
nature of the adenovirus vector that
causes it to be more effective in
producing an immunity that actually
matters and it may be that
the range
of uh
uptake
in
the range of uptake that is liable to be
very great in the mrna vaccines has some
implication for immunity but it's very
hard to say specifically yeah
could environmental contaminants like
endocrine disruptors
uh be contributing to rapid onset gender
dysphoria or just gender dysphoria
yes yeah of course yeah i think the
rabbit onset uh
is
is largely social social contagion
um but the
rise in actual gender dysphoria as
opposed to um
gender non-conformity
uh
and as
opposed as separate from
uh
just not
you know not being like traditional
people have been
um
seems likely and we've talked about this
elsewhere seems likely to be um at least
in part a result of endocrine disruptors
and we and we know that in other species
uh some of the some of the pesticides
and herbicides that are in the water
supply
are causing greater rates of for
instance hermaphroditism in some
amphibians
and um that these have effect have
effects on the steroid
hormones
including the sex hormones
yeah absolutely
let's see what what kind of time are we
at
we are at
all right
um
just two comments here i'm in new
zealand i fear we are moving towards no
jab no job
i take c d c d zinc and
i
yeah that's an unfortunate
it's ridiculous
uh here's another comment i graduated
from evergreen from task in 2012 i met
you both on campus
great people thank you oh thanks someone
named randall um i don't you don't say
if you were either of our students you
say you met us on campus i'm guessing
that means not
um not our student but but thank you
um
let's see where can one find or purchase
your published analysis the cova
situation that's on my sub stack
um just
naturalselections.substack.um.com i
think
you can find that there
it's just a lot of these that um
would you consider making an online
course on evolutionary biology of the
kind you might see on masterclass
skillshare brilliant etc
as a means to supplement your income
you know we've talked about this at
times and we used to talk about it
more and we definitely talked about
doing trips
which we just haven't talked about at
all since covid because who knows at
what point that's going to really be a
plausible thing that people will be
engaging again in again but um
online classes are going to have such a
hard time doing
what we did
with students
where we had so much time with them
every week for weeks and months
that um
that i at least even you know i've
gotten several you know please including
from some of the organizations that you
know would make it very easy
logistically you know just you know just
supply the content
uh and it just it feels like part of
part of the magic was exactly about the
interaction
and about the extended time and the in
the really getting to know the people
uh with whom you're in the classroom
yeah there's no way to there's no way to
do it that would equal that but it
doesn't mean that there's not room
for a
curriculum that would have some other
effect but you know it you know yes you
cannot do what we were doing in the
classroom online
so what do you think about doing it yeah
i would consider doing it um
but you know there's a question you know
it sort of fits in the same place as
a book
right that would
describe evolutionary content in a in a
systematic way
yeah and i guess you know i just
i love writing and i want to write more
books after this one that we have coming
out and i tend to
um
and it as it turns out i loved teaching
um but
they're not the same thing
and pretending that one is the other
seems like a big mistake so you know i
specifically for instance architected
you know things that were
the things that i was most proud of were
things that were invisible to the
students and you occasionally one of
them would discover oh you know i i i
discovered this thing and i think it's
because you introduced that back then
and then three months later and it's
like oh because i put that in that order
and was putting easter eggs and you know
all along and you know and and maybe you
saw them maybe you didn't
um but
that sense of discovery is part of what
is so remarkable for for people to have
and it gives you more of a sense of
ownership and you know the kinds of
assessments the you know these
elaborate
you know fictional scenarios these
evolutionary scenarios in which um i
would ask
students to figure out you know if
given given this fictional scenario what
else would be true predict the mating
system and tell me why you know predict
predict the sex ratio and tell me why
this sort of thing
and i don't see a way to do that in an
online class in which you don't already
you have the shared history with the
people and then you know if you do pull
it off how do you do it a second time
yeah no i i am not disagreeing with you
i would do not want to do an online
class yeah but you know is there room
for delivering a curriculum that
contains
useful stuff there's room for that and
you know maybe a curriculum that other
people you know something that has a
deliverable such that other people could
could use it yeah you know such that the
person starting you know being a ninth
grade biology teacher
um could use pieces of for instance yeah
all right have either of you read any of
the studies on
i never know how to pronounce this word
either
artemisinin extract which is from
artemisia annua a plant
uh in regard to its ability to inhibit
spike protein adhesion to ac receptors
i have not um i've
some i've heard some little glimmers um
but this is this is one of these plants
that actually is thought to have
a number of
interesting properties and i don't know
really anything more than that about it
i haven't read about this but i'm
interested
um
why is college for breadth of education
isn't that supposed to be high school
um
well increasingly i'm not sure how much
of any of this i believe it's obviously
about
creating a mind that is capable of a
great many more things than it would
otherwise be capable of and some of it
doesn't belong in school at all and the
fact that we relegate this stuff to
school is a result of our
misunderstanding of what school is for
and then there's a question about us
just completely under leveraging the
opportunity that comes from having
students present in such an environment
and you know
i think
you and i spent
a year
considering how to build a replacement
educational system yeah higher ed system
and
i think we settled on a lot of the
groundwork that would do it and i don't
want to be responsible for thinking
about
this old broken system that is now
finally in complete collapse and what
might be made better about it if we
tinkered this or that because i think
the point is um
you know good riddance
yeah very much so so maybe like
maybe we'll just finish on this and riff
a little bit here um
i honestly don't i neither know
the history of what people have claimed
the various stages of schooling were for
except for higher ed i have i have done
some research and digging on what people
have claimed
uh higher ed was for and have written
and published some on that but um
why
why we assume that what has been said in
the past is relevant today
or that it was actually what it was for
given that we know that at least with
the k-12 schooling the compulsory
education was not actually what it
claimed to be for it was not it was not
really for students originally and
that's not to say that it couldn't have
been co-opted for the good of students
but it largely it largely wasn't so
um
especially in the modern era
the idea that
you go to college to become a specialist
uh is seems completely backwards because
modernity
is unpredictable from decade to decade
from year to year to some degree i mean
this will be easy for everyone right now
to recognize from you know from week to
week
so the idea that um you should become a
specialist in college unless and then
assume that the thing you graduated
graduate being able to do at 21
is the same thing you'll be doing 50
years later at 71. well
who can look around this world right now
and say yeah there's something that i
could be prepared to do right now and in
50 years i can be just doing the same
thing so that's what that's what
training and specialty does for you as
opposed to being
learning how
to think broadly and to assess pattern
and to deal with uncertainty
i think um
one thing i always thought
every time i started a new class and met
a new crop of students was this is a
great
job but this is far too late to be me
meeting these people
and that um
probably it was good for me to be a
college professor because the material
that one is expected to deal with
college-level material you know
is worthy material to be thinking of
right
but
the point was we were dealing with a lot
of damage done by the systems that
caused the
thinking
mind to atrophy right and so the point
is college becomes a remedial activity
and it should not be a remedial activity
it's only a remedial activity because
you screwed up the education of these
people in
grade school and high school
and
were you
to simply
not screw up their education
right were you to give them things that
were worthy of their mental capacity and
that challenged them and that excited
them and that caused them
to learn then the point is i don't even
know what college would be for at that
point right because you could do college
level material with high school students
if you hadn't hobbled them in grade
school
and none of this needs to happen it's at
best it's a failure born of not enough
economic resource to do the job right
right but i mean at the very least just
notice the following thing
we pay teachers like crap
right
we pay teachers like crap
means obviously
that either
you're going to get people in the
profession who do not
regard their own earning potential as a
significant factor that's the best case
scenario that we are abusing people who
will accept it because they have a
higher priority but of course the
regimentation of school means that those
people aren't likely to be satisfied by
the job in the first place so by and
large
we are driving the best people away from
the idea of teaching kids
because it doesn't pay like a job that
we take seriously and it doesn't give
you the freedom to innovate anything
that would entertain you enough to be
worth your time and so
you know
how on earth are we shocked that a
system that sabotages the entire faculty
that are in you know en entrusted with
educating these kids
that it fails to produce highly educated
kids who then need what we used to
deliver in high school when they get to
college because nobody taught it to him
in high school right we sabotaged the
system and then we're shocked that it
didn't work and the point is hey
you want to
not have that failure
stop sabotaging it right pay people you
know i i always thought it would make
sense to um try to
induce people to teach uh grade school
and high school temporarily on the way
to a career right to make it something
that somebody was actually going to
contribute to these fields would find
worthy both economically and because it
was an interesting thing to do because
we incentivized it well i mean those
federal programs exist we we had
students who who went on to do that but
it's it
they sort of exist they sort of exist
exactly they're paying limitations of
what they could do yes we are not
serious about it and if the fact is if
you were serious about it you really
want to educate kids or do you just want
to talk about it if you really want your
kids educated
then uh you know
pay
pay more until you get the quality of
people teaching your children that you
might get and then give those people
freedom to do it properly right yeah i
mean
pay more isn't going to do it so i'm
glad you you added you know give them
freedom but of course
the money is the easy part to give them
freedom is so give give them freedom is
tough given all of the constraints
currently in the system
and it's particularly tough
given um how teachers are being trained
yeah there are plenty of amazing people
who want to go into teaching who then
become
basically incapable of teaching as a
combinatorial result of the the policies
they have to contend with the teaching
to the test the you know the lined up
rows and all of this and the glazed over
drugged students
and um and the fact that what they were
taught in in their school of education
was
often a bunch of garbage well the whole
idea of school of education is probably
preposterous
in its own right right if you have
somebody
you know who knows a hell of a lot about
chemistry or history or biology or
physics or whatever it might be
right and they are attracted to a
profession in which people are trying to
get in because it pays well and you
you know just simply
set the bar high enough on your success
as a teacher that the people who end up
sticking in the profession are people
who actually succeed in educating right
the point is this is not a hard problem
to solve if you want to solve it at the
current uh economic level of commitment
well good luck you're not gonna and so
you know i know you mean when you say
that the money is the easy part you
don't mean it's easy you mean it's the
easiest of all the things you have to
solve on the other hand
if you created demand for those
positions and then you simply evaluated
who was any good at it having learned
something i mean you know we didn't have
to go to a school of education
yeah i mean i think i think i disagree
with you um in your conclusion here
because i just i don't think
i don't think at this point there's a
huge amount of people who would be
talented teachers who are waiting to go
into the profession but for i agree they
don't they don't exist now but that's
also because the graduate education that
we should be delivering in order to make
people into high quality scientists for
example doesn't exist and so you're
looking you're tuning into one place in
a system that is in collapse right but
so that's why i'm saying i just you
would appear to have been have given a
prescription that i don't think is a
prescription that could possibly work
right now well it's a prescription that
if you deploy it without actually
educating anybody about how to do
science won't work because then the
people who would go in who know
something are few and far between to
begin with but you know from the point
of view of what's the problem
um well we actually did see um
we did know
some really extraordinary scientists who
said
to hollywood that i give up
i give up i'm i'm done with this
particular kind of rat race that i've
been told is what i need to do and they
actually they went not to some high
school actually we do know some people
with you know phds in science in
sciences who are doing high school who
are also doing this what i was thinking
of first was the community colleges yeah
um and you know just some you know
evergreen was not a community college
but um you know we
similarly it's like well you know with
people you know people with these
degrees are supposed to go to an r1 and
do you know high-powered research jobs
and do with that horrible sounding life
you know or you could do this thing
where you can still do the you know the
academic thing and earn tenure and all
but actually focus on
the teaching
you know rather than the research at
least as it usually looks um so that you
know there are a lot of ways that people
but i think it's still a tiny number of
people really who are choosing to say
okay you know what
i'm not doing the standard rat race
thing i'm go i am going to go and the
other thing is you can't
the way it's structured at the moment
you have to if you want to go into high
school teaching um it's a private school
and so you're relegating you know the
public the public school kids never get
access to these people who actually are
highly trained in the sciences because
they would have also needed to go back
and get like an education degree which
is insane right
if they were you know had any
self-respect going through one of these
education degree programs would cause
them to explode i mean they would just
you know you're not talking about the
students now no i'm talking about their
teachers and the point is
even going back to get that degree isn't
just a matter of going back to get that
degree it's having to endure what is
being dispensed in the schools of
education yeah and so my sense is
i do not know the problem for which
school of education is a solution
oh i agree
i agree but i guess so i agree with that
i also don't think
that
paying teachers more as much as i think
teachers should be paid more
can solve the problem now no
you've got too many different problems
the only reason that paid teachers more
is the solution is because what we need
is demand that will cause the highest
quality best teaching types to to land
in those positions and to stick
starts to tweak the incentives in the
right direction right and yeah you know
at the point that people are trying to
get into teaching because it's a good
paying job then the point is then you
can be selective about who you keep you
keep the ones who are effective at
reaching their students and you know
this is something evergreen completely
screwed up right
evergreen
brought people in who looked promising
on paper
and then it had an impossible time
getting rid of them and so the point was
yeah faculty so there was no selectivity
you know it was a
you know is it a good guess that this
person will be able to teach in this
totally unusual model right and then the
point was well how many people did we
know
who either
uh played some game where they were
popular with students but didn't teach
them anything
or didn't give a damn what students
thought about them because they knew
there was no way to get rid of them
right it was like a large fraction of
the faculty and
um you know the number of people who
came in and who were like wait a minute
i can figure out how to teach people in
some way that nobody's ever done before
and the point is you know it takes years
to make use of that and figure out what
actually does work but
there were a small number of very
committed people but you could have the
job was so desirable from the point of
view of the freedom to do something
different yeah that you could have
filled the entire faculty with oddballs
who were interested in exploring how to
teach differently and yet right now you
absolutely could have at a you know
medium-sized public liberal arts college
like evergreen with regard to you know
the k-12 teachers though
um
it's
in part in part again the problem is
does what work at small scale work at
larger scale and
you know given that class sizes are more
than 40 students in some places and
that's not
the only you know and a teacher may have
four or five six different classes every
day how how do you develop relationships
oh yeah how how can you possibly develop
relationships with these with all of
your students and absent relationship
how beyond a just already on board
innate desire to learn
um does a student who comes in going
like i'm about to have my time wasted
come away with any other conclusion
of course they're going to feel that way
right no but that's a system
built to fail or neglected into oblivion
or
you know some combination of those
things
but
you know getting good people in
is a matter of paying them enough that
they don't you know that they're not uh
driven out by the sheer austerity
required in order to keep doing the job
and selectivity requires that lots of
those people be
uh be induced to take it up so you know
no if you deployed that one solution in
isolation it would not work but is that
an essential
aspect yes you need to pay people enough
that the best people want to go into it
and that you can then be selective about
only keeping those who are effective at
it i agree
all right i think we've reached the end
all right of episode 93 q a
uh please like share subscribe to all
the channels consider joining us at our
patreons
uh send logistical questions darkhorse
moderator gmail.com
do various other things um
consider supporting our sponsors for
this week if you are in the
in the market for a coffee alternative
that tastes delicious or
various things that you
could find on
certain
very common internet stores but might
prefer to find public goods
um
yeah maybe maybe that's it yes maybe
that's it take a look at the calendar at
some point in the next few days take a
look at the calendar figure out where
you are look up where vitamin d comes
from and if you're in the northern
hemisphere get to it because there's not
a lot of time
yeah and um regardless of where you are
on the planet take a look at the sky
tonight the moon is full it's going to
be full for a couple of a couple of
nights hopefully one of those nights you
get a clear enough sky
uh try to get out around when it's gonna
come up
and uh
and just just drink it in yeah drink it
in it's the same moon for all of us it
ought to be a uniting force it is it's
the same moon for all of us ought to be
uniting force
in the meantime
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everybody
you